[Music]
you all came highly
recommended you know the rules no real
names no Back
stories no s so whose kid is she a very
wealthy man who's about to be $50
million
poorer I'm here to make sure you're safe
what's your name mine's Abigail you can
call me Joey do you have any
kids I have a little boy see you in
hours do you know what a pinky promises
if you behave and do as we
say like pinky promise you it'll all be
over soon
Joey yeah I'm sorry about what's going
to happen to
you what the
we got to get out of
here I think she knows
something
guys
guys oh no
what the is that thing we kidnapped
a
[Music]
vampire a ballerina
vampire okay how do we kill a vampire
what are we talking about like an an
rice or a True Blood you know Twilight
Stak through the heart daylight is a big
one all right let's go kill us a
vampire
ready
[Music]
[Applause]
vampire what can I say I like playing
with my
phone whoa whoa whoa she's
flying
a I hate
ballet